ben sasse who has
invoked the ire of many conservatives in
recent
weeks and months because he's he was a
never-trumper and
he often attacks members of his own
party and he was censured by his own
state republican party sas had a great
performance yesterday
going after xavier becerra becerra
was the former attorney general
of california and a real
real radical becerra
went after nuns tried just like the
obama
biden administration did becerra went
after nuns because he wanted to force
them to pay for abortion drugs
and contraceptives so sas grilled him on
this point
i tried to say to senator grassley i
understand that
americans have different deeply held
beliefs on this particular issue
and and i absolutely respect that by the
way i have never sued
the nuns any nuns i have taken on the
federal government uh but i've never
sued
any uh affiliation of of nuns
hold up point that there before we
really get into what sas says
it is technically true that becerra
never sued nuns
what he did was even crazier
he wanted to sue nuns the federal
government under the trump
administration
would not let him sue nuns and to try to
force them to pay for abortion drugs and
contraceptives
so becerra sued the federal government
so that he could get his right back to
sue the nuns
and try to force them to pay for
abortion and contraceptives
sas totally not going to take his lame
excuses
you know well you're an incredibly smart
man you know well that what the federal
government did
was make sure that you couldn't target
the nuns so you sued the federal
government because the federal
government said
the nuns didn't have to buy
contraceptive insurance you can put 17
layers of
you were following the law to go after
the federal government for administering
the program or doing x or doing why that
made it difficult for you to
for california to administer the program
but it was just about nuns buying
contraceptive coverage
was there something else the federal
government did that you were suing them
for
when when in the case called california
versus little sisters of the poor
senator the case was not again that was
not the name of the case
and what i will tell you is that our
actions were based on
trying to follow the law that when the
federal government took action which we
believe did not
comport with the law at that point we
took action
and our action was based on the law and
so as i've said
we may disagree on how we see this and i
respect the differences that we may have
but my action was to follow the law no
it wasn't your your action was to
uh attack the law to
dispute the law in court because the
federal government
interpreted this federal law and
you didn't like it because the
government's interpretation said you
couldn't sue the nun so stop
please stop this ridiculous posturing
this ridiculous proceduralist posturing
and get to the heart of it you wanted to
sue the nuns to make them pay for
abortions
and contraceptives and
the federal government didn't want you
to do it so you sued them
speaking of trying to grow the american
family speaking of
trying to reverse this course of
national death and decline
one good way to reduce that is to stop
killing our
babies and to encourage a culture of
life rather than a culture of death
but becerra's a good politician you know
he's a
he's a shrewd guy so he knows how to
portray this where if you didn't
know the facts of this case and you just
watched this exchange maybe you'd say oh
they both got good points in but sas
sas got to give it to him he won't let
up
what about the law as the federal
government's conscious
conscience exemptions applied in the
case where you sued the federal
government
what about the law applied to anybody
except the nuns and other
similarly situated religious
institutions
you were targeting religious liberty
because what
what yeah what about the law i know
we're talking about the what about the
law though
what were you trying to do with the law
pal and this
this is the big issue right now under
moderate joe biden's administration
you've got the leader of hhs pushing
politics toward encouraging a culture of
contraception
and abortion this
is the issue you've got
this world in which the
the government right i think the
conservatives for too long have
kind of embraced this libertarian idea
that there's the government and the
government can never do anything and
anything the government does is bad and
you know we can't ever use political
power that people give us
and uh this has given the left the
opportunity to completely transform the
culture but
politics and culture which is a little
blurry line in between those things
they can encourage things one way or the
other and by the way when they say
one thing they exclude other things
so getting back to what we're talking to
at the top of the show
if you have a a culture and a culture
backed up by a political regime
that says that it is simply a fact that
men can become women
women can become men and it's bigoted to
say otherwise and you
drill this into kids heads from
kindergarten onwards
and then you use the law to say we we
should
pump kids full of puberty blockers if
you know
jane likes to play football at
thanksgiving or something
and we should fundamentally change their
biochemistry what you're doing is you're
saying
this is the way the world works
and all of those incentives are going to
be compounded
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you